فنلندا ستصبح غدا عضوا رسميا في حلف شمال
الاطلسي بعد ان صادقت جميع دول حلف النيتو
البالغ عددها 30 على بروتوكول انضمامها
ووصف امين عام
التاريخي مؤكدنا انه سيجعل فنلندا اكثر
امانا ومع هذا القرار تكون فنلندا انضمت
قبل السويد الى حلف النيتو بسبب استمرار
معارضه تركيا في المقابل نددت موسكو
الاسبوع الماضي بقرار انضمام فنلندا
والسويد الى النيتو معتبره ان روسيا لا
تشكل تهديدا لهذين البلدين وتقدمت كل من
السويد وفنلندا بطلب للانضمام الى حلف
شمال الاطلسي بعد بدء الحرب في اوكرانيا
اذ وجدتها في الحرب تهديدا روسيا كبيرا
للامن الاوروبي
هذا اسبوع تاريخي للنيتو غدا سنعلن
ترحيبنا بانضمام فنلندا لحلف الناتو العضو
رقم 31 ما سيجعل من فنلندا اكثر امانا هو
الحلف سيزداد قوه كذلك السويد ستصبح اكثر
امنا وكان هذا نتاج الدعوه التي قدمها
النيتو لانضمام فنلندا والسويد للحلف
العام الماضي وكانت اجراءات اتمامها سريعه
بالنسبه للحلف وكلنا نتفق على ضروره انهاء
اجراءات انضمام السويد بشكل سريع